who's the one that spoke before Jin Jin
right mr. Jin yeah what's up BTS or me
back here with some BTS reactions it's
funny because a couple days ago we were
talking earlier every cover BTS in a
while and then here they go you know
showing their support for black lives
matter and then they drop a couple of I
think it was a stream but now there's
like two videos on trending it's not
like all right we got a cover we were
actually gonna cover the music
performance one first but we saw that
there's no English subtitles
everything's like so speaking in Korean
is what it says like yeah we know we're
gonna wait to cover that put it up on
YouTube a lot of our audience is non
Korean speaking oh my gosh the subtitles
do yeah we don't really often cover
music videos on a child because majority
of them are either like to monetize
right away or they're blocked worldwide
but on our patreon John actually covers
music videos weekly he's got up on a lot
of BTS over there but yeah you know we
want to get back into the motion of
covered in more BTS up on the YouTube
platform and stuff but if you want more
music video reactions head on over to
our patreon page today the plan right
now is to join them a lot more often as
well in those videos and yeah we have
you know weekly Q&A podcast TV show
reactions but hey let's do this
BTS commitments come be BTS commencement
speech dear class of 2020 Congrats
anybody who graduated remotely cares
about them BTS that's right
drop out and start a band
[Music]
yes and this is our third class of 2020
it's been a strange year so far but you
made it today we might not have flowers
we might not have graduation caps what
we do have is possibly the most special
graduation ceremony in history never
before have so many gathered to
celebrate the graduating class for their
achievements and their dreams hmm you
could be watching us from your bag or
from your living room alone or with
somebody wherever you are
you would all soon be breaking out of
one world soar into another ten ten
years ago it's snowed really hard on the
day of my middle school graduation I
remember that day clearly because I took
a picture with my friends and kept it as
my messenger profile for the rest of my
school years on that day I was just a
boy who had clothes just one chapter
grade to pen another and I remember that
feeling it's really thrilling
breathtaking was a moment I felt most
like me myself a feeling I wanted to
hold on to forever so as a fellow
individual in his 20s all the way from
Seoul Korea I want to say
congratulations we're very excited for
what lies ahead of you regardless of
where or how far you are we hope our
stories today can give you some sort of
comfort hope maybe an even bit of
inspiration okay
BTS give everyone j-hope Wyatt jungkook
is talking now do you know one
interrogate a start-up siding on YouTube
a punk album a key dr. Smith a go do a
case checkup good today
remember the same video that one Jade
okay
Torro Vonnegut in them you know hungry
epistemically woodworking watchable
he'll fetch it doesn't mean I'm about to
Kio bismillah hollandaise to the chicken
in the room on Monday he doesn't know it
to do well tomorrow I got closer they
got in vodka
I'm Janice honey some tightening of at
abandoned a tournament a league a
monitor :
Smita Europe man can UFC : what's in
their crew Madonna's answer okay Fiona
Bernanke eat olive oil good as a chicken
methionine Jeremy I'm go terrific cause
bitumen some chicken is there a member
the from cane say Smita chronica you're
not under dual blue/yellow Mondavi esse
hunger room Chicago good nope she have a
system you
Jocasta thank you ten students in Amira
Sonu Nigam talented of security o Canada
soon as i belong to an erotic TV doha
janicoo is a mafia
perhaps unbalanced or obscene yosuta
occasional so you need a negotiator
yourself and watch communist oh I do
hang doomed Ubud engage with Rockwell
tarunabh so valid sing with the Racine
County which open balmy treated oysters
Damita Tom DeLay economy much no arrests
of Okajima Sumika Dugan Iranian kaydara
Smita that's how a change from gun 2020
cousin and tells us through it Jimmy has
to be done then I blew up in Madrid
encoder
get a samhita chun-yin superheated o
been body buddha-nature up searching
bitter Chicago Sparta they doin Goomba
lasagna oh dude Ohio border get that man
to a person who can machine whatever
isn't gonna really get roads in qh2
vergis Tomita yer yer cool do do do
Hanan goddamn han gauri miss Aisha today
Indonesia is your neighbor laughter so
you uncle anyway computer beautiful good
ad yarn a gay bar across the world
hmm Nancy oh she got me da Jonalyn
Talladega no meeting go captain Krunk
even Amita cleveo Hasharon Ikeda Trapani
tienen inoko some money according to
management motivate him to her
instructor bootable money to tap a
booster under voodoo come Nirvana free
energy an adjustment to casa milà
checkup good
Keshava younger days silicon you so
maybe 10 when I asked you never to talk
to me that otogi not - a chronicle
cleveo batters me given ago Mira
how much - I'll go check him and EKG
done hands enemy Ramana can connect
Google Talk Ramon I think a miracle
the hanging hands on me and by Chuck
success you got a team and a great day
oh boy yes - Mira
hello given everybody know what it's all
cool table
jaqen caputo sooner yes me me de soto
Creepo no wonder to throw sir comenzó su
top sheet cou bananas on a Luigi
peshitta
who do you need are getting tears in nan
Gong we judge in Punta Mita oh you're
gonna talk abou man what the hell is a
gray well I'm yeah todo husband Anita
jury made of elephant Lambda Chi Minh
Amita
Bonjour Robert since Mirage académie des
grandes - Capitan kuk-ja epsilon or tile
or the oxygen and a shave and him
Dinkelman in see Rico Putin gave money
to Oberon cotton chicken Michigan L
second Eagle Meghan's tottemiro'
pondered upon karmic internship Tony
magnet Amida Buddha Chechnya Kissimmee -
Cosima Manitoba morado contention Tamil
Tiger Hamid hi we're a telugu smita Yong
Yong is I'm so gay that single target
semen
Hoagy I didn't ask him to kiss me de
yogi hungry dananana critical so did run
into che that any agent who can god I
ate an inch on my couch just me to
Kissimmee de woody able to that I don't
own a psycho or territory man so what is
fin c'mon c'mon you little Akshay in
some terrible sorrow which was Lucas
Smita Daniel oh so do your underwater
Alameda de rerum undergo so much that
woman back Taryn calm okay
data gotcha Marie sook is here keeping
us all who is our prodigy Orochi doc we
talk about Hammond sauce watching
community me de Klerk tic-tac momento
anything ugly sorry Iroquois he'll take
up a service once not a sinner humble
bee don't wanna go though I'm because
another humbled and - Dante - one table
than 70 tonnage in ingwavuma - don't
yank it sorry Tabatinga Damita your
noggin dou Sigma Towanda I mean
Kunichika beaten like a salty county lo
la da da cunha
Bank okay or a bar in something energy
like a terrible energy either awamiya
palpable energy good enough she wish me
trabajar Camila closer
Koki Oh Katya they anything Erica no
Gozen are oh that's a senior and Casilla
cleveo luminaire una cometa her sister
you got and then child her Sihanouk well
poor Widow kill
Oh another cream it up actually run now
for overcoming my conditional Naruto
come young donkey Oh Grod avocado
chicken water gosh Shannon who enjoy
pasta which man Europe undertow Saturn
Anja Kron genomic EMU is from gonna be
okay man Chiquita Krypton a year at sea
boy Chinese Union you already had she
clicked on GMOs baby Josh para poner
gotcha
sorry Shannon a champion Daniel Smitha
I heard Cinco de puta Mo Rocca cool she
talked to the Dutchman should show the
onions Hugo magic Tessa more kids will
go home on shuttle Cochin into ricotta
headquar croquette Jerry catch osmeña
second table to go up prom world see
what type with Ana him de Madrid come on
come on you're opening a kid Yakuza
Sacramento cumin Dorado Creek it's a
recording hi Kiera hello Nikita liquid
channel car challenger chemicals me de
grado amezo channel owner a yakitori
Smita
owner Pierrot soil rock chicken an edema
vanish a conditional in our chakra told
real sweet throw dorayaki Smita Creek
one Jenga you're robbing a Yankee Joe
salucci killer comida do class of 2020
I hope our stories which all today so we
really really Frank was still feel very
unsure and unsettled as we speak just
like that day we left the school gates
for the last time on graduation day
some say we have achieved so many things
but we stand no different from any other
youth in their 20s our graduation caps
still pressed to our heads and awkwardly
peering into the face of reality
the reason unforeseen events completely
change our plans
and the sense of loss and anxiety we
felt then are still with us today
the fear of an Oscar future as our daily
lives turned upside down is a moment of
realization of the self the realization
of what makes me truly myself asked us
musicians we are pulling ourselves
together by making music you write songs
we produce and we practice as we think
about the people we love and it connects
to the world during such difficult times
and with music we hope we can bring you
smiles and courage again and V dis
mention memos and photographs for us our
way of remembering and communicating is
to make music for you it could be
anything
an army we're alone but also together we
may be seen each other through just a
camera in this small screen but I know
your future will bloom to something much
bigger than magnificent graduates
friends family faculty today I stand
with us the largest graduating class in
history
[Applause]
[Music]
hey man they're probably the only people
there like I'm off the joke you got to
make now when you see people gathered
yeah so it's really serious
aside from every other people this is
your entire circle this is beautiful I'm
glad they came out to do this you know I
mean most of their audience are grown
adult American men in their late 20s so
thank you for doing and we really
appreciate that thank you so much for
directing this toward us specifically
generally a younger audience but
everyone I know is like in their 20s
these guys right well an even parents
and stuff be getting into them I love
commencement speeches from famous people
generally speaking yet a lot of
beautiful words of wisdom throughout
it's a unique thing to get during this
time because yeah it's like my
girlfriend works at a school and it's
sad that a lot of people who are
graduating don't get to have an official
graduation ceremony
especially those moving on from middle
school to high school or high school to
college you spend all those years and
they're supposed to be like monumental
days for you and now you're having this
very unique experience of not being able
to have it the way you envisioned or
thought of might be the way most people
have never had it before yeah exactly I
didn't have a high school graduation
John did mm-hmm you did he went to an
all-boys school I did yeah I'll touch
each other
mm-hmm and it's all for my groups yeah
sing together ours fails did I go to
yours I did we went to Malibu after yeah
yeah buffalo burger let's talk about
that for the residue it
[Laughter]
with my family I submitted some papers
so I didn't have to finish that's what I
did but what they're talking about here
I feel like everyone makes like some
very powerful points but the one that
really stood out to me was sugars starts
off mom I perceive it to be a little bit
on the darker side of things a little
bit more serious a little gritty but he
made some solid points about things that
I personally really connect it with I
think what gin and sugar center are
probably my favorite one I can get a
little bit of something from all of them
but the one that most connects to me is
sugars I'd imagine the one though what
gin said might connect with you more
yeah between the two of us first of us
the beautiful thing about having seven
of these guys right perspective gotta be
one that applies to most people it's
like before was like which friend's
character are you
now it's which BTS member are you
friends cast plus one but with sugar
talking about isolation and how there's
a lot of things in life you cannot
control one quote I heard forever ago is
you can't change people but people can
change themselves and he's talking about
how the only thing you can really
control is you for the most part you
know in terms of this isolation period I
have learned a lot in my time of only
allowing John in my the thing is I've
been doing this channel by myself for
the most part before John and I
partnered up so I've had the feeling of
just every day and especially on the
weekends of I just got to get the hell
out of my home I just got to get the
hell out of my home and you too but I
don't want to be my ultimate end goal
it's like I have other passions and
YouTube was supposed to be that stepping
stone to getting there honestly I feel
like I've improved as a human being I'm
less of a people pleaser
than I and I used to be it really helps
that we shouldn't be hanging out with
people there are times on the weekend
where I just stayed in and wrote and it
was a great feeling of being like wow I
don't feel this pressure to have to go
out and and see people like I love my
friends but a lot of the time too you do
have to make that sacrifice
hanging out kind of be enforced in
isolation you learn to make the most of
it I've really learned to love my home
in my neighborhood taking advantage of
like catching up on things to read or
write or he'll give me something just as
leisure like just watching the certain
show I haven't been able to watch our
movie there are ways to take advantage
of the isolation periods gonna be
different for everybody of course but I
think there's some benefits here John
you want to talk about what Jin said
yeah sure although I think there is
something else to be said for the
isolation too because it's not only
about alright we're talking about Jin
over I nailed it ya know but like
obviously we're all under these strange
world circumstances right now but there
can be a feeling of isolation that comes
just after graduating after spending so
much time with a group of people a
pending on what your rapport was like
you know either way you're leaving this
institution you're leaving this group
and for a lot of people you might be
going on to an experience where it's
just gonna be you in a brand new
fishbowl and that can be kind of an
isolating experience as well I remember
I went to my high school knowing nobody
and you know that can be its own kind of
daunting experience too and and the
world is like that you know as well in a
more scary way because if you're
graduating college or grad school or
whatever and yours going out into the
world you know there aren't defined
tracts you got to go seek them out and
so that idea that you can in that
isolation kind of focus inward and
really work on yourself I think is a
great idea and yeah go into what Jin
said you know I think that's also a
thing that a lot of people can feel
because I don't know what it's like you
know in other parts of the world where
education is better than it is here it
seems as though especially here we're
pushed to know like even you'll see kids
in elementary school junior high be like
this is to college and this is the
career but I know a lot of people come
out of schooling or go through schooling
still trying to find that passion and
I'm hauling and I feel like this world
puts a pressure on you society and
certainly capitalist society puts a
pressure on you to be productive right
away and to turn it around immediately
and I think that yeah while you
shouldn't have learned the master not
being that way that's the beautiful
thing a rebel
I know but you know I mean that there
are ways in which no matter what even if
you don't know exactly what you want to
do you have to rise to the occasion and
that is a tricky thing a lot of time
yeah
making your own space can be the key to
helping that process along because the
better you can ground yourself the
calmer you can make yourself the more
you can take what might feel like a
lonely feeling or a feeling like you're
behind everybody like that's the thing
I've heard artists especially touch on
is like oh man I was feeling so down
because I felt like I was behind
everybody I know everybody had an idea
of what they want to do they went and
did it or even not related to other
people and so that's an aspect to where
really searching your soul is a big
piece of this the sentiments they
brought out were very beautiful but also
very indicative of the reality because I
think it's easy to look at a graduation
scenario and be like yes you know here
are the song you know it's our time but
there's a lot more to it and then
there's a big world that's awaiting you
there are a lot of people again I've
heard speak on that that like I felt so
behind but you never quite know what
it's gonna be that leaves you and these
guys all said and obviously they didn't
expect to blow up and become BTS but a
couple of these guys had stories work
especially V him saying you know like I
wasn't always the self-starter I wasn't
always the guy who was like vehemently
following the passion until I really
thought about some things and opened up
and found the right channels and I think
that's really important as much as you
do have to engage with society you do
have to get out there and go make your
way I do think that there are things we
can do to make people feel less bad
about maybe not having everything
figured out right now or being a little
questionable about where your passions
lie and whatnot because life is
ever-changing you're always gonna be
learning and I think that was a good
thing for jungkook to bring up is once
you leave school you're still gonna
continue that process of learning it's
just gonna be kind of curated by you and
so yeah I thought this was really
well-rounded and really really beautiful
and hopefully it inspires people to even
while they're making their way in the
financial world still keep a view on who
they are and and that growth and where
that can lead you because that's where
the beautiful dream stuff can really
take root so yeah
now do you want to talk about Jimin
there's a quote from the song sunscreen
song don't waste your time comparing
yourself to others sometimes you're
ahead sometimes you're behind the race
is long in the end it's only with
yourself now if I give you pleaser
now if I could constantly apply that
quote oh my god would my life be amazing
in any field a former teacher of ours
told me before we were in high school
that once you graduated high school he
realized almost every single work circle
he's ever run into is a little version
of high school anywhere you put humans
together around the core idea becomes a
high school you know I didn't know what
that meant until I became an adult
yeah I've come to find out that's very
much true being an adult is not as rigid
of a thing as you think it is no as it's
led to believe cuz like on YouTube you
know it's easy sometimes you're like hey
in this certain topic or category we're
number one here in this video and then
other times you're like wow we're so low
who hear so low on the view count here
at the end of the date it's like it
doesn't really matter and a lot of times
I do have to take a break from like
looking at my friends videos cuz I can't
compare myself especially in like la
it's easy to really compare yourself I
think so sometimes it's like yeah I
won't worry comment someone do these
things all to out the detox a little bit
to get yourself re centered and refocus
because one phrase I heard forever ago
is a big mantra in my life for a while
called Kaizen constant growth constant
development and the only thing constant
about life has changed so it's important
that you keep on learning and keep self
educating that's probably the biggest
thing a lot of people constantly look
for inspiration without self educating
inspiration and motivation is obviously
necessary I forget who said it here but
someone was talking about being able to
remind yourself that it's okay that's
such a small phrase that I think can be
taken for granted one person I've
listened to in the past a few times
despite whatever controversies you might
have had recently is Tony Robbins and
Tony Robbins said that he noticed like
the
best mentality to persevere with is the
idea of no matter what happens to me in
life I'm gonna be okay
the more I can remind myself of that the
better off I am because it's easy to get
stressed out about we always find our
things to replace our stresses we might
accomplish one thing that alleviates
that stress and then we find something
else growing up it's not easy but the
whole point you got to keep growing and
the best way to do it is intentionally
with your own direction you'll say go
with the flow believe it or not you're
going with someone else's flow way ahead
so you got to be able to find a way to
lead yourself someone raised a great
question here years from now how will we
look back on this time right now it
feels like 20 20 sucks balls it just
does it feels like it's one of the worst
years ever and it's easy to stack it up
and it's not because of social medias is
like there's like terrible things that
have constantly been happening and what
if there's like some slingshot effect
what if there's some great change
changes that occur from some of these
things that wouldn't have happened if it
wasn't for having to endure some
terrible things through hardship to the
Stars hopefully we will feel that way
especially in 2021 when the Snyder comes
that everyone in South Korea is looking
forward to that yeah yeah hey they're
gonna also put up funding for the Snyder
guys yeah yeah after donating all this
money just civil rights and one thing
I've heard many times is opportunities
usually followed by difficulty and vice
versa difficulty is followed by oh I
think I've heard many times is
opportunity followed by difficulty
difficulty followed by opportunity so
yeah I mean like while we're in
difficult times I've know some people
who have really inspired me and the way
they're using these times to create
opportunities not just in a business
sense but in a life sense I feel very
empowered by so yeah I don't know who
we're talking to right now I don't know
if you're even listening
I don't know how bored you are but if
you're here than graduating if you're
here the thing I always tell people is
some people will ask like what's like
the number one piece of advice you can
give me my advice is always be mindful
where you get your advice from
that's always my face be mindful where
you get your advice from because it's
important to know what is seeping into
your brain and who is planting those
thoughts is a childhood stuff is it's
negative thinking that other people have
instilled on you or is it very just
direct advice of someone who gave you
advice today or yesterday be mindful of
the advice we're giving you you know
just be mindful but keep educating
yourself I don't mean that in just the
formal sense I mean that in like life
and adulthood sense and if you're a
little kid watching step fun mess around
who cares you're young life's too short
anyway well at least until you're like
18 yeah really take advantage of time
because you get to a certain age you'll
wish forever that you'd used it better
unless you did use it well yeah because
once the Machine sets in and you are
accountable for bills and [ __ ] there's
no more of that yeah until you retire or
make too much money all right guys well
thank you for being here thank you beats
yes for putting this together subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell check us on patreon
for all them goodies last but not least
lb lb John lb TS hahaha I'd love to give
a commencement speech to you the day
that you graduate from BTS fan club
University because you know all their
real name moving on from BTS is that
what your no because she's gonna become
a BTS scholar she's gonna make a real
life living this way she's gonna look
within she can take their advice because
lb is country you know when John looks
at me a lot that means he's not super
confident in what he's talking about
welcome points things out about my own
behavior makes the problem yeah man lb
you're freaking great I'm just gonna
drop the jokes you're wonderful you've
been with us pretty much drop the jokes
job you know especially on this BTS
journey you've been one of the people
who has been most vocal most just
willing to chip in and have fun about it
and you've sent me on some pretty
interesting rabbit holes in terms of
their storyline music videos as well as
several of our other patrons but you
were definitely
who stands out among our army so uh much
love to you and I hope that you're
staying sane in Arkansas it's good
thanks man
that was good man thank you talk from
your heart it happens once in a while
yeah when I yeah when I bring it with me
we friends on Facebook al
[Laughter]